um so obviously I want to get your take
because
uh there are a few cities in hip-hop
right now that I feel like are very
instrumental to the culture
um
the torch always had a presence in
hip-hop
but it's always been kind of like
it's like Eminem or Big Sean or you know
even guys like back in the day like slum
Village but like the street side was
always kind of like more underground
which is crazy you know what I'm saying
but nowadays man you guys are kind of at
the Forefront of a lot of influence and
a lot of culture and every uh label is
swooping everybody up from the city
um
at like a Pace that I haven't seen
um and you know obviously guys like Sada
baby guys like T Grizzly all these guys
kind of kicked the door down for the
generation that's popping right now what
do you think it is about Detroit where
like everyone's finally kind of paying
attention and given like the Cur like
the respect that y'all deserve in terms
of the industry I think after T Grizzly
did it if uh it put a lot of people in
rooms that we couldn't get in like and
then people started just networking with
other people
it's like on the um Detroit get a lot of
recognition because like everybody be in
the streets so like right after T
Grizzly got out there like other people
was in rooms with other artists that's
also in the streets I feel like so they
got to doing music and hanging out with
each other and doing stuff like that so
I just felt like that was big that after
cider did it it just kicked some more
doors down didn't do like a Snowball
Effect Doug did it yeah Doug I actually
think like
I think um
T was the first to do it
Sada did it the
um solid did it like on the talent wise
Sider did it the best T was the first
and I think Doug just went to fire this
like yeah as far as like networking and
having platinum records and stuff like
that knife knives baby face
Babyface Ray he doing his thing his face
killing it
um Vaso it's been dope to see his career
um baby money Tay like everybody
networking with people and that's right
I love to see that part of Goldie James
staple for Years buddy been in stable
he's been in staple for a long time
especially in that like very my favorite
type of hip-hop yeah I think he don't
get enough flowers sometimes sure for
sure like Bo Jackson's so crazy it's
great shout out to shout out to bully